So student Lisa asks, what would be different in
world where almost everyone was programming
literate. So this is the core question and obviously
I feel that it would be great to have such a world
that’s why we are trying to encourage as many
people as possible to take this class and hope
you’ll encourage any non programming literate
people that you know to take the next version in
this class starting in April.
There are lots of things that understanding
programming even at just a basic level and I think
many of you are beyond the basic level now if
you’ve made it this far in CS101, but in terms of
the things that you interact with and the things that
you see in the world, almost all of them are
controlled by programs these days and people
who understand programming can relate to those
things and have better way than people who don’t.
And some of this can be sort of fairly obvious
things when you interact with a website and you
can tell, well they’ve got some bugging it because
the programmer didn’t think of that both branches
of the NIFT test and if you are a programmer or
you at least understand about programming that
you maybe have a better sense of what is going
on but you also can get a lot more familiar by it
because you know well this is something any
programmer who knows what they are doing
should have test before and understand what’s
going on and it’s really annoying that you have to
deal with their mistake.
Other things you probably have a better
understanding of how complicated it is and how
hard it is to get things right that you might be a
little more forgiving when things break and have
better ideas about well this is probably why it’s
breaking, let’s try to use this tool or use this
product in some slightly different way. So that’s
one of the reasons. The other reason I think is
there are lots of things that people encounter
every day that if you know a little bit about
programming instead of doing a lot of tedious work
as a human you can find a way to automate that
and save yourself a lot of…
There is a good example of this right here in our
office. So when recording these video we generate
hundreds every week to get the classes out for all
these courses and they are all named kind of
default things by the video camera and video X, X,
X, 1, 2, 4 and whatever but what we need to do
that is that organize them like date and time and
course and what not. And so whenever video
editors wrote script, we’d just kind of the
programming that you got from here and a little bit
previously to do this automatically. Whenever we
record videos we just give it to her and she sorts it
automatically and saves the video editors hours of
time.
Okay, that’s great and I think people once you get
a little experience with programming you’ll see
things like that every day that you’re seeing people
could be yourself but it’ll less often be yourself
spending their time doing tedious things that are
not fun for humans. That you could write a few
lines of python code to solve and so I hope, at the
end of this class and I think by this point in the
class many of you really should be at a level
where you’re instead of just solving the problems
that we’re giving you in the homeworks, you’re
finding real problems in your life and in your
friends lives that you can solve by writing a little bit
of code. So, I hope everyone will be doing that and
spreading the value of programming literacy
beyond that, beyond just yourself.